nous allons suivre le déplacement à des
supporters de versailles jusqu'à
périgueux pour le quart de finale entre
bergerac et versailles un périple de 600
km et ils sont motivés
[Applaudissements]
on va les citernes
oh oui
ça fait donc trois heures et demie que
les supporters versailles et son parti
depuis un versailles à mes côtés à
anthony alors anthony comment ça se
passe du coup ce déplacement bah ça se
passe plutôt bien c'est une ambiance bon
enfant ont joué moi on vient à un moment
magnifique parce que des moments comme
ça on a envie de rap a peut-être pas plu
du tout on sait pas on espère qu'on en
verra d'autres mais faut profiter il
faut prendre à fond tout ce qu'on a là
maintenant et en profiter un max en
trois ans en club ça fait ça vous fait
quoi de voir versailles à ce niveau là
la compétition j'ai déjà vécu une partie
parce que quand on a battu dijon une
fois en huitièmes de finale mais bon là
c'est un rêve c'est vraiment quelque
chose de sensationnel
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé à périgueux après sept
heures de route donc on n'est pas venu
pour rien on est venu pour marquer un
maximum de buts là aujourd'hui ya le roi
soleil qui avec nous il va peut nous
porter chance et on espère se qualifier
et récupérer le trône
[Musique]
après 14 minutes de jeu versailles ouvre
le score par inzaghi diarrassouba 1 0
pour les joueurs de la cité royale
[Musique]
au même moment explosion de joie devant
l'écran géant installé place du marché à
versailles
1 0 ce sera le score à la pause
ouais c'est bien ça joue bien et ses
buts a fait beaucoup de bien hoa
et surtout il détourné très bien y avoir
un très bon pressing on arrivé là
mais dit il à faire un bloc plus parfait
je pense que on a bien joué cette
première mi temps et
[Musique]
mais la fête est gâchée à la 90e minute
4 essence marque et égalise pour
bergerac
[Applaudissements]
90 les deux équipes vont devoir se
départager dans une terrible séance de
tirs au but il ne reste plus qu'une
chose c'est les avoirs aux penaltys en
est à plus de ça je tape tourné le dos
là un peu stressé quoi
ça versailles aussi les milliers de
supporters des joueurs de la cité royale
vont stresser jusqu'au bout font
après trois tirs au but réussis de
chaque côté à bergerac manque ce penalty
en tirant sur le poteau de diouf lé
marque le but libérateur
pour la première fois de son histoire
versailles se qualifie pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france c'est une
grande fierté d'avoir un club qui fait
un tel exploit pour tous notre ville
summerside
c'est magique les normes versailles club
de nationale 2 sera en demi finale de
coupe de france la belle aventure
continue
ça y est assez faire versa il tend demi
finale de la coupe de france ils
viennent de battre aux tirs au but
bergerac ici à périgueux dans une
ambiance fantastique du connaît des
versaillais justement des aléas
rencontrés ils sont fous parce qu ils
communient avec les joueurs en ce moment
alors c'était comment ce match fera
comme vous voyez c'est la folie
on va voir comment les autres ce
supporter
notre fidèle supporter un petit village
mais qu'est ce que je dis résultat
victoire aux tirs au but victoire aux
tirs au but ouais on est en demies on
est en demies on est en demies ya plus
de voir c'est super on a gagné on a
gagné en 2001 j'ai plus de voix j'ai pu
te vois la gueule
et on gagne ou on gagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est dit et puis c'est pas une
récompense c'est une joie pour le club
entier c'est pas vrai qu'on prince on
les a eus c'est ça qui compte on est
trop salée très bien c'est qu'on va pas
dormir la nuit on va fêter z toute la
nuit et là bas c'est incroyable et on
gagnera en prochain en irak du coc
finale en décrochant la troupe ça c'est
sûr
ça doit
je ne
c'est mission accomplie mission
accomplie pour les joueurs pour le staff
et pour les supporters voilà il est bien
tôt 4h30 du matin et tout le monde tout
le monde est heureux cette qualif tout
le monde est heureux aussi de rentrer se
coucher je crois et on espère qu'il y
aura de plus en plus de monde à
montmoreau pour soutenir l'équipe